[Applause]
no I felt like if I had any any chance
at all it was very free Arden in the
game I thought that pretty you know
pretty quickly million it was starting
to worth what it must [ __ ] we set it
look looks a little bit better for work
which realistically it is just working
yeah I mean I was wanting to this
solution
you know just pushing through five I
mean do you just not think this was
no I spent a lot of time there so that's
obviously what I was during but I didn't
say to work very well when Hannibal
efficiency selling basically you know
it's half of the position is very dry
very equal fair enough okay let's open
to questions actually mr. Carson could
you works about this mysterious roof
roof roof he was the basic idea is that
if I make a move with let's say I make a
move with the cream then he may gain a
temple with this pastry and then we
decide an awesome I mean that was the
basic basic perfect mainly it was about
it was about the father or not the file
at this point other moves are most
likely not
to make much of all okay next question
yeah please yeah okay video today
showing our openings
[Music]
[Applause]
you said you said I will have a video I
just wanna make sure that we're
understanding you correctly and you've
not seen the videos
[Music]
no I I I can truthfully say I haven't
seen the video but I'm aware of it is
[Applause]
yeah but being comfortable no I think
this particular game is not the one that
gets your you gets your heart racing so
III think that's the the main reason
that there's no look to us to Magnus
using specific reasoning behind which is
something fishy defense and the Fabiano
if there was a preparation because well
I mean first of all I think you should
have a little more respect towards the
English opening it's not the most
offensive opening but it's still not a
defense
I'm necessarily
but no there was no special significance
I mean I am required to wear that we are
currently in England part of the United
Kingdom the country that this particular
okay nice name doctor but I feel like
that's that joke well I mean there must
have been right
[Music]
[Music]
I wouldn't say that it's an advantage I
think that's that's a very gutterbrush
conclusion to make on a very limited
sample size but it's true that mike has
been comfortable so far but I think
there will be there will be sterner
tests and again
okay I think one final question please
yeah please newspaper and what are your
plans for the right thing I don't know
totally prepare for for the next game I
mean to to regain some energy after this
grueling so you have a rest
you